[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem besonderen
Jahrestag an meiner Seite ist für den
Sport Katja streso guten Abend vor genau
einem Jahr hat Russland die Ukraine
überfallen
[Musik]
365 Tage Krieg 365 Tage tot Leid und
Widerstand Präsident selenski sagt 2023
werde das Jahr des Sieges über Putins
Russland
141 Staaten in der UNO vereint gegen
Russlands Krieg der größte Teil der Welt
steht weiter entschlossen an der Seite
der Ukraine Deutschland sagt weitere
Panzer zu
und das teure Gas und die Folgen der
Chemiekonzern BASF streicht weltweit
2600 Jobs die meisten davon in
Deutschland
[Musik]
der 24 februar vor einem Jahr hat die
Welt verändert seither führt krimisches
Putin Krieg in Europa gegen die Ukraine
er lässt auch Schulen Wohnhäuser und
Kliniken bombardieren mit westlicher
Unterstützung wehrt sich die Ukraine
bislang hartnäckig gegen die russische
Übermacht der ukrainische Präsident
twitterte heute ein Jahr des Schmerzes
und des Leids aber auch des Glaubens und
der Einheit Volker Duce
früh am Morgen eine Schweigeminute bei
einer unangekündigten
Gedenkveranstaltung mit dem Präsidenten
mit viel Sicherheitskräften fast ohne
Publikum vor der Sophienkathedrale
silenski sagt das ukrainische Volk habe
nach dem Überfall nicht die weiße Fahne
gehisst sondern gekämpft und dieser
erbitterte Widerstand für die
letztendlich zum Erfolg führen 2023 so
die Botschaft des Präsidenten werde zum
Jahres ukrainischen Sieges werden
ich möchte euch allen sagen allen die
für die Ukraine kämpfen und hier leben
ich bin stolz auf euch jeder von uns ist
stolz auf euch
für viele die heute auf Kiosk Straßen
unterwegs sind ist der Kriegsbeginn ein
einschneidendes Erlebnis
dieser Tag hat mein Leben in ein vorher
und ein Nachher geteilt ich war ein Jahr
lang nicht zu Hause habe meine Familie
nicht gesehen also für mich ist es ein
schrecklicher Schmerz
und da ist dieses Gefühl der stolzes des
Kreuz der Wut dass man einfach nicht
loswerden kann
der Tag des Rückblicks ist auch der Tag
des Blicks nach vorn und da liefert
Polens Ministerpräsident moraviewski
richtige Schlagzeilen denn er bringt zum
Ukraine besucht die ersten vier Leopard
2 Panzer mit
Katrin Eugendorf wie viel
Widerstandskraft haben die Menschen noch
nach einem Jahr im Krieg
ja ich erlebe die Ukraine an diesem
Jahrestag voller Schmerz aber bei aller
Verzweiflung auch voller
Entschlossenheit diesen Krieg
weiterzuführen fast jeder hier hat Opfer
bringen müssen teilweise sehr sehr harte
Opfer und die Menschen gucken auf ein
Jahr zurück in dem sich ihr Leben
komplett verändert hat dennoch das was
Präsident selenski gesagt hat dass er
sein Land hier auf dem Weg des Sieges
sieht da steht die große Masse der
Bevölkerung dahinter für die Ukraine ist
klar es gibt hier nur einen Ausweg wenn
Sie Ihr Land nicht preisgeben wollen das
ist dass sie diesen Krieg weiterführen
müssen und irgendwann Russland besiegen
müssen das ist dennoch bei allem
durchhalte Willen ein sehr sehr
schmerzhaftes Gefühl weil sie wissen die
Opfer werden weitergehen die Ukraine
wird in ein weiteres Jahr des Krieges
gehen und im Moment ist nicht absehbar
wann das Land wirklich Frieden finden
wird
Katrin Eugendorf live aus Kia vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzung
ein Jahr Krieg das heißt auch ein Jahr
vergeblicher Bemühungen Russland zum
Einlenken zu bewegen die
unvollversammlung wurde in der
vergangenen Nacht recht deutlich
141 der 193 Mitgliedstaaten stimmten für
eine Resolution die den Rückzug von
moskauz drucken fordert China enthielt
sich und stellte stattdessen einen
eigenen zwölf Punkteplan vor darin
fordert Peking einen Waffenstillstand
und baldige Verhandlungen aber auch ein
Ende der westlichen Sanktionen
zur Stunde Tag der Sicherheitsrat der UN
in New York dort ist Johannes Hano wie
kommt die chinesische Friedensinitiative
an könnte die etwas in Bewegung bringen
bislang hat außer Russland und China
niemand dieses chinesische
Positionspapier hier überhaupt nur
erwähnt was daran liegen kann dass die
Generalversammlung ja gerade gestern
erst einen Friedensplan skizziert hat
wie er aussehen könnte auf Basis der
Karte der Vereinten Nationen man
zweifelt die auch ein bisschen an der
Glaubwürdigkeit und Ernsthaftigkeit
dieses chinesischen Vorstoßes die
Vorschläge sind doch sehr allgemein und
wahre gehalten wenig konkret ein
Beispiel da wird davon gesprochen dass
die Souveränität aller Staaten
garantiert werden müssen es wird aber
nicht gesagt ob die Souveränität gemeint
ist die Souveränität der Ukraine in
ihren völkerrechtlich anerkannten
Grenzen oder eben auch die Souveränität
die Russland beansprucht über die
Gebiete in der Ostukraine da hätte der
chinesische Außenminister heute eine
Möglichkeit gehabt hier vor dem
fahrsicherheitsrat klare Worte zu
sprechen ist aber gar nicht gekommen
anders als fast alle anderen Länder die
ihre Außenminister geschickt haben hat
China nur ein Diplomaten hier
hergestellt und der hat das Papier
einfach vorgelesen und es sieht ein
bisschen so aus als würde ich China
diesen eigenen Vorstoß selbst gar nicht
so ernst nehmen
wie viele Menschen in diesem Krieg schon
ihr Leben verloren haben lässt sich noch
nicht mit Sicherheit sagen bei den
Streitkräften sind die Verluste immens
nach westlichen Schätzungen wurden bis
zu 180.000 russische Soldaten getötet
oder schwer verwundet auf ukrainischer
Seite sein ist 100.000 sein
laut UN wurden außerdem mindestens 8000
ukrainische Zivilisten getötet und 14
Millionen Menschen mussten fliehen die
Bilanz eines Kriegsjahres von Christian
Volk
für viele Ukrainer beginnt es mit
heftigen Explosionen am Morgen des 24
Februar 2022 bringen russische Truppen
den Krieg ins Land in der Hauptstadt
Kiew folgt der Luftalarm tausende wollen
so schnell wie möglich weg Russland
greift zu Beginn von vier Seiten an auch
aus Belarus und den Separatisten
Gebieten in den ersten Kriegstagen
erzählt die russische Armee deutlicher
Geländegewinne vor allem im Süden und im
Norden doch wenige Kilometer vor Kiew
Gerät der Vormarsch ins Stocken
wochenlang umklammert Russland die
Hauptstadt kämpft aber gegen unerwartet
starke Ukraine und muss schließlich
abziehen
was zurück bleibt sind entsetzliche
Bilder im Kia war vor Ort Butcher liegen
die Leichen Hunderter Zivilisten
Kriegsverbrechen die Moskau bis heute
bestreitet
wenig später spitzt sich die Lage im
Süden zu Russland legt die Stadt Mario
Poll in Schutt und Asche Soldaten und
Zivilisten verschanzen sich eineinhalb
Monate im asof Stahlwerk es wird zum
Symbol des ukrainischen Widerstands im
Sommer wächst die Sorge um das
Atomkraftwerk saporisha es ist von
russischen Soldaten besetzt und immer
wieder unter Beschuss beide Seiten geben
sich gegenseitig die Schuld
ab September haben ukrainische Soldaten
Grund zum Feiern
sie können im Nordosten und Süden große
Gebiete zurückerobern die westlichen
Waffenlieferungen zeigen offenbar ihre
Wirkung
Russland in der Defensive Präsident
Putin reagiert mit der Annexion von vier
ukrainischen Gebieten und das obwohl
Moskau die Regionen nicht vollständig
kontrolliert
mittlerweile gibt es auf beiden Seiten
kaum noch Gelände Gewinne stattdessen
tobt im Osten ein Stellungskrieg mit
heftigem Beschuss und nach einem Jahr
Krieg kommt nun die Sorge der Ukraine
hinzu dass eine neue russische Offensive
bald noch heftiger ausfallen könnte
die Zivilbevölkerung leidet massiv unter
diesem Krieg hunderttausende sind
obdachlos traumatisiert leben in
ständiger Angst vor neuen Luftangriffen
was das für eine Familie in harkev
bedeutet zeigt Katrin Eigendorf
zum ersten Mal seit langem sind Nikita
und Anja mit ihren Eltern auf dem
Spielplatz doch lachen haben die Kinder
verlernt seitdem vor einem Jahr die
Bomben auf Rake fielen direkt am ersten
Tag des Krieges flüchtete die Familie in
die Metrostation im Osten der Stadt 800
Menschen suchten damals Schutz unter der
Erde in einem Waggon traf ich sie im
August
wie ist es für dich hier unten zu leben
wollte ich von Anja wissen ich habe mich
schon daran gewöhnt es ist normal
es ist normal möchtest du nicht nach
Hause hast du keine Sehnsucht Gutschein
nein
Zwölfjähriger Bruder war damals krank
wegen der Feuchtigkeit 10 Monate lebten
sie so dann mussten sie die Metro Räumen
ich treffe sie in ihrem Haus
wir wollten noch den Frühling dort
verbringen hier ist es doch so
gefährlich wie geht es den Kindern
möchte ich wissen beide wirken traurig
und ängstlich Anja möchte in die Metro
zurück
dort hört man die Knallerei nicht
einmal hatte ich meine schwarzen
drahtlosen Kopfhörer in den Ohren ich
habe die Lautstärke voll aufgedreht und
hörte trotzdem die Knallerei
die meisten ihrer Freunde haben die
Stadt verlassen Schulunterricht gibt es
nur online doch oft fällt im Haus der
Strom aus die Sachen liegen gepackt wenn
die Angriffe auf Rake wieder schlimmer
werden wollen sie zurück in die Metro
in Moskau gab es heute kein offizielles
gedenken zum Jahrestag dieser
spezial-operation wie der Krieg dort
immer noch genannt wird dabei haben ja
auch 10.000 russische Familien ihre
Männer Väter Söhne und Brüder verloren
gegen den Krieg aufzubegehren traut sich
kaum noch jemand
Patriotismus und eine hohe
Opferbereitschaft das fordert Putin von
seinem Volk auch ein Jahr nach
Kriegsbeginn steht eine große Mehrheit
hinter ihm glaubt der Staatspropaganda
die ganze Welt ist gegen uns die NATO
Staaten bekämpfen uns durch die Ukraine
liefern Ausrüstung an die Nazis wir
freuen uns darauf dieses Jahr zu
gewinnen hoffentlich
Kritik ist gefährlich geworden in
Russland Vladimir kisselow hat viele
Jahre als Ingenieur in einem
Rüstungsbetrieb in nischeninoff
gearbeitet bis dort im November
Flugblätter aufgehängt wurden auf denen
die Gewerkschaft verkündete dass sie die
russische Armee finanziell unterstützt
ich bin auch Gewerkschaftsmitglied und
das Geld wurde zugeteilt ohne dass ich
gefragt wurde da habe ich beschlossen
diese Flugblätter einfach abzureißen
inzwischen ist der arbeitslos Kollegen
haben ihn verraten er wurde festgenommen
und angeklagt kam aber mit einer
Geldstrafe davon dann entließ seine
Firma ihn es wundert ihn nicht dass
viele Russinnen und Russen putins-
[Musik]
nicht nur das Schweigen ist groß sondern
auch die Unterstützung in unserer Firma
sind zum Beispiel etwa 90% dafür
schon kleinste Zeichen des Protests
erfordern Mut mitten in Moskau liegen
heute ein paar wenige an einem
ukrainischen Denkmal Blumen nieder kurze
Zeit später gibt es Festnahmen
fragen wir unsere Korrespondentin in
Moskau für Bega wie ist dieser Krieg in
Russland zu spüren
ja mittlerweile hat der Krieg eigentlich
alle Aspekte russischen Lebens erreicht
da ist zum Beispiel die Wirtschaft
gerade wird darüber diskutiert wie
Firmen dazu gebracht werden können
größere Abgaben anders Staatsbudget zu
machen und zwar so dass das noch
irgendwie nach Freiwilligkeit und nicht
nach Zwang aussieht viele Menschen hier
fürchten um ihre Jobs oder kämpfen mit
den gestiegenen Lebensmittelpreisen im
Privaten trauern sie um gefallene
Verwandte oder Bekannte oder sie haben
Angst davor selbst eingezogen zu werden
und über all dem herrscht eine große
Unsicherheit nämlich die Frage was der
Präsident seinem Volk wohl als nächstes
zumuten könnte denn eines ist ganz klar
Vladimir Putin ordnet diesem Krieg alles
unter
danke schön für diese Einschätzung aus
Moskau für das
Deutschland hat der Ukraine heute vier
weitere Leopard 2 Panzer zugesagt damit
wären es insgesamt 18 der Jahrestag des
Kriegsbeginns stand überall im Land im
Zeichen der Solidarität mit der Ukraine
zwischen Münster und Osnabrück bildeten
am Nachmittag etwa 20.000 Menschen eine
rund 50 km lange friedenskette bei der
zentralen Gedenkveranstaltung in Schloss
Bellevue war die gesamte Staatsspitze
versammelt der Bundespräsident betonte
dieser Krieg geht uns an Frank Buchwald
Schloss Bellevue Gedenkfeier für die
Ukraine die deutschen bewunderten ihren
Mut sagt der Bundespräsident ihren
Willen und ihre Kraft Berlin Teile ihre
Trauer und helfe militärisch und bei
allen Kontroversen und manchmal
schrillen Debatten bin ich sicher wir
werden das auch weiterhin sein deshalb
sage ich auch mit Blick auf das was noch
vor uns liegt auf Deutschland ist
Verlass die mädchener Nadine
aus Kiew zugeschaltet Präsident selenski
Deutschland hilft uns die Ukraine vor
dem russischen Terror zu schützen und
Deutschland wird am Tage des Sieges der
Freiheit mit uns sein es wird mit uns
sein wenn wir unsere besetzten Städte
und Dörfer aus der russischen
Knechtschaft befreien
über dem Reichstag Wehen die Farben der
Ukraine und vor der russischen Botschaft
erinnern die Menschen an den Überfall
vor einem Jahr inzwischen steht dort
auch das Wrack eines russischen Panzers
ziemlich brutal und gewalttätig und es
lohnt sich nicht ein anzufangen und das
sieht man an dem Panzer ganz gut am
Abend wird dieses Mal zum Zentrum einer
solidaritätsdemo für die Ukraine
ich war immer eigentlich Pazifistin aber
ich denke wenn jemand angegriffen wird
dann muss man dem helfen da musste
dieser Tag vor einem Jahr das war der
schrecklichste Tag meines Lebens ich
glaube nicht daran dass Putin den Knopf
drückt es wird er nicht tun ein Jahr
dauert der Krieg nun in der Ukraine und
der Widerstand gegen Putin wirkt
entschlossener denn je
der Krieg hat auch Deutschland verändert
zwei Beispiele rund 1,1 Millionen
Menschen sind aus der Ukraine hierher
geflüchtet vor allem Frauen und Kinder
viele Kommunen sehen sich bei der
Unterbringung am Limit und Energie ist
immer noch sehr teuer Erdgas kostet an
den Märkten gut 50% mehr als vor
Kriegsbeginn Strom 27% mehr Heizöl und
Sprit über
12%.blick zurück
es ist Krieg in Europa mit sich
Sondersendung sickert ein fast
unwirkliches Gefühl ins Bewusstsein der
Deutschen und die Ahnung für uns alle
wird das schwerwiegende Folgen haben wir
erleben eine Zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die Welt danach ist
nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt davor
im März explodieren die Energiepreise
ein Entlastungspaket für die Bevölkerung
wird geschnürt das erste von dreien und
ein grüner Wirtschaftsminister muss für
ausbleibende russische Energie fossilen
Ersatz einkaufen wo er ihn kriegen kann
auch bei den Scheichs in Katar ab März
wächst der Strom der geflüchteten aus
der Ukraine gut eine Million werden es
schließlich sein
der Sommer bringt ein seltsam leichte
Schlagwort zum Kriegsjahr 9 € Ticket wie
der Tankrabatt ist es von Juni bis
August zu haben und soll das Leben
einigermaßen bezahlbar halten
ab September liefert Russland überhaupt
kein Gas mehr für viele werden die
Preise für heizen und Essen zum ernsten
Problem die Inflation klettert Richtung
10 %. der Kanzler hält mit seinem
Doppelpunkt dagegen 200 Milliarden für
die gaspreisbremse und für einen
einmaligen heizzuschuss für alle
im Herbst schlagen die Kommunen Alarm
für die geflüchteten Fehler ist ein
Wohnungen Kitas und mehr 37% der Ukraine
wollen inzwischen dauerhaft bleiben Bund
und Länder streiten wie das finanziell
zu stemmen ist dann die große Sorge vor
dem Winter reicht die Energie wieder ein
Machtwort vom Kanzler drei
Atomkraftwerke sollen bis zum Frühjahr
weiterlaufen
derweil guckt Deutschland erstmals
gebannt auf seine Gasspeicher die
schließlich doch voll werden und
schließlich doch reichen durch den
ersten vielleicht aber nicht den letzten
Kriegswinter
auch die Wirtschaft leidet unter den
hohen Energiepreisen Deutschlands
größter industrieller Gasverbraucher die
BASF schließt jetzt mehrere
Chemieanlagen auch im Stammwerk
Ludwigshafen der Konzern hat weltweit
mehr als 111.000 Beschäftigte
2600 stellen will er jetzt abbauen die
meisten davon in Deutschland Christel
Haas und Anna duda
es ist eine Mischung aus Angst und
Resignation mit dir die BASF Mitarbeiter
heute nach Hause gehen alleine
Ludwigshafen fallen 700 Stellen weg das
ist natürlich
ist das wahrscheinlich eine eine
Maßnahme die getroffen werden muss
natürlich aber
es wird hoffentlich auch wieder besser
werden
BASF muss einsparen 2600 Stellen von
über 110.000 weltweit die meisten in
Deutschland
energieintensiver Anlagen werden
geschlossen Folge der hohen
Energiepreise genannt werden aber noch
andere Gründe die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der Region leidet zunehmend unter
Überregulierung sie leidet auch immer
mehr unter langsamen und bürokratischen
Genehmigungsverfahren und vor allem
unter hohen Kosten für die meisten
Produktionsfaktoren investiert wird
jetzt vor allem in Asien der Betriebsrat
drängt daher darauf dass Stammwerk in
Ludwigshafen für die Zukunft zu rüsten
wir fordern die Transformation zu
nachhaltigen Produkten zu grüne Energie
das schnell zu machen beschleunigt zu
machen der Markt schläft nicht die
Befürchtung nicht nur B alsf sondern
auch andere Unternehmen könnten
Deutschland den Rücken kehren für die
Wirtschaft ist das kein gutes Zeichen es
wird jetzt darum gehen diese Abwanderung
auszugleichen vielleicht durch den
Aufbau neuer Industrien aber die
Herausforderung ist da groß ein
chemie-riese und sein Sparkurs und die
Frage wie zukunftsfähig der Standort
Deutschland langfristig noch ist
der Tarifstreit im öffentlichen Dienst
geht weiter verdi hat für Montag neue
Warnstreiks angekündigt Schwerpunkt
diesmal Nordrhein-Westfalen mit den
Flughäfen Köln-Bonn und Düsseldorf die
Arbeitgeber hatten gestern unter anderem
fünf Prozent mehr lohnangeboten Verdi
nannte das eine Frechheit und lehnte mit
dem deutschen Beamtenbund ab die
Gewerkschaften bleiben bei ihrer
Forderung von 10,5%
. und jetzt zum Sport da sorgt eine
17-Jährige für vorure ja und zwar bei
der Nordischen Ski-WM in Planica
Slowenien die Rede ist von Natalie
Armbruster ein neuer Name in einer fast
neuen Sportart die 17-jährige gewann
Silber in der Nordischen Kombination und
damit als erste deutsche kombiniererin
eine WM-Medaille
Jubel bei Natalie Armbruster ein
zufriedenes Grinsen bei kombiniere
Legende war ein Buch Armbruster schreibt
den Planitzer WM Geschichte die 17 Jahre
alte Schülerin springt 98 Meter Platz
zwei hinter der Norwegerin westwold
Hansen die ist auch in der Loipe die
stärkste Armbruster taktisch klug zu
Silber
denn da ich dachte einfach jetzt muss
ich einfach alles geben und ja
dauersiegerin westdeutsch Hansen mit
goldarmbruster springt auf zwei Bronze
geht nach Japan
bei der Auslosung in der Fußball Europa
League hat der SC Freiburg das
schwierigste Los erwischt im
Achtelfinale treffen die Breisgauer auf
den italienischen Rekordmeister Juventus
Turin Leverkusen bekommt es mit Vereins
Budapest zu tun die Bayer 11 hatte den
Sprung unter die besten 16 Teams nach
einem spektakulären Erfolg bei AS Monaco
geschafft die Abi verwandelte den
entscheidenden Strafstoß zum 5:3 im
Elfmeterschießen
und auch Union Berlin begeistert weiter
den Berlinern wurde fürs Europa League
Achtelfinale unions aus Belgien zugelost
nach einem leidenschaftlichen und
kämpferischen 3:1 gestern gegen Ajax
Amsterdam
sie tanzen und sie hüpfen mal wieder die
eisernen selbst der Trainer kann es kaum
noch glauben es wirklich der Wahnsinn
Fußball schreibt manchmal seine eigenen
Geschichte die Geschichte gegen
Amsterdam ist mal wieder eine der
Effizienz Handspiel besser Elfmeter für
Union Knoche mit etwas Glück zum eins zu
null kurz vor der Pause juranovic mit
etwas torwarthilfe 2:0 Amsterdam mit 73%
Ballbesitz aber nur einem Tor kudos kurz
nach dem Weg Wechsel die Antwort von
Union kommt doki 3:1-achtelfinale und am
Sonntag geht es in der Bundesliga zum
Meisterkampf mit den Bayern
und morgen gibt es wieder Wintersport im
ZDF 49 geht's los bis zur 19 Uhr danke
schön das Wochenende wird noch mal
winterlich die Details hat gleich
Christa Orben Marietta Slomka meldet
sich mit dem heute journal um 22 Uhr
live aus Kiew und wir sind morgen wieder
da danke für Interesse ein schönes
Wochenende auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend am Wochenende klopft noch
einmal der Winter an kräftige Schauer
gehen jetzt nämlich mehr und mehr in
Schnee über heute Nacht ist das vor
allem im Norden und in der Mitte bis in
tiefere Lagen der Fall im Stau des
Erzgebirges gibt es mit diesem strammen
Nordwestwind auch Schneeverwehungen am
meisten so um die 10 cm Neuschnee fällt
aber am Alpenrand dazu singen die
Temperaturen noch vier bis minus zwei
Grad morgen gibt es ein bis sechs Grad
am Rhein 7 bis 8 Grad und hier im Westen
und auch im Norden ist am ersten Mal
Sonne drin sonst wechselhaft Schnee
Regen Schnee und Graupelschauer Richtung
Osten ist auch mal länger anhaltender
Schneefall dabei bei diesem strammen
Nord Nordwestwind fallen im Stau das
Ärztin wird und der alten noch einmal um
10 cm danach beruhigt sich das Wetter
etwas ab Sonntag die Nächte werden
knackig kalt und die Sonne kommt immer
mal häufiger raus tschüss